well it is every car enthusiast's dream
race your own car around a nascar track
this weekend your dreams can come true
and you'll be helping out a great cause
jc of course stop by at the las vegas
motor speedway for more
yeah guys it's called laps for charity
and it's an annual event and as a car
lover it is going to be awesome this
weekend this is paulette
she is with speedway charities so paula
tell everyone
what exactly did you guys do yes so
speedway children's charities
is hosting on sunday uh january 31st
from 12 30 to 4 we're hosting our annual
laps for charity
and it's all to raise money to help
local children in need what the great
thing is is that any car
any car can go we've got a bunch of cars
here chris go ahead buddy
let's send some of these cars out so how
does it work on sunday people need to
register online
yeah so your viewers your listeners any
street legal vehicle can come out to the
speedway
it's between 75 and 100 dollars between
five and seven
laps it is such a blast you get to go on
the same banking
that nascar drivers are on i mean how
special is that
and then we're going to take everyone's
photo in their car so you'll get a nice
download free download just display
anywhere you want holiday cards whatever
you want
it really is an experience to come down
here and if you're a fan of nascar
you've watched all the races on tv and
this is where the legends
this is where it happens i mean you are
literally going to go up on the banking
you follow a pace car 75 miles an hour
and for those people that say they do
more on the highway it's a lot different
when you're on las vegas motor speedway
super speedway
and again you come out everything though
because of covid
everybody has to register online so we
won't be taking any money
on sunday so everybody can register
until sunday morning at 6 00 a.m
and a couple things i want to point out
because you said too you're gonna get an
official car
so if you love your car no matter what
kind of car it is right you're gonna get
a cool photo of your car
on the tracks it's so cool being on the
track but it's
it's more than that because when you get
down here you're going to drive through
the tunnel
to come out here and to pit row where
all the nascar's all the action
it is so exciting and kids six and older
can be in the back seat so it is such
here comes the this is lap number one i
know and they get to go five to seven
times can you believe that just
back and forth we've got a cadillac out
there we've got a camaro we got a
corvette
and they'll have someone in the flag
stand waving them on and you'll get your
checkered flag at the end just like the
races
now uh what a cool thing too if you've
got kids
that love nascar what a great surprise
exactly we're going for a drive you came
down to the speedway and then you pull
on to the track i love it yup
six six and older we put them six and
older and they have to be in the back
they can be in the back seat
and it's a great outing for your family
it's social distancing at its best okay
so we're going to not have to take money
this year so that's why we're doing it
all online to keep
everybody safe and listen the best thing
is you're having an awesome day and
you're raising money that's going to
stay in southern nevada to help local
children in need and listen pandemic
we need the extra money and you get to
hear the airplanes
thank you so much it's happening on
sunday you can register online
we'll send it back to you guys in the
studio my car is over there i'm going to
get my car
back to you guys in the studio yeah they
were not excited about that at all it
didn't sound like it was going to happen
that's
awesome all right we'll be right back
here on